as the public prepares to get vaccinated
one group may be hesitant to roll up
their sleeves
denise valdez has more on the fears of
pregnant women and the vaccine
in today's health watch denise
well christian pregnant women were not
actually part of the clinical trials for
the vaccine so the trouble is there's
really no
safety or efficacy data on how the
nursing mothers or how pregnant women
are going to respond to the vaccine
so the cdc is saying that pregnant women
can choose to get vaccinated and the
american college of obstetrics and
gynecologists advise
that covid19 vaccine should not be
withheld from pregnant women
now it's important to remember that
pregnant people who contract the
coronavirus
face a higher chance of hospitalization
so they need to decide whether they
should get the shot
and protect themselves against a
potentially life-threatening disease
we don't know what long-term respect
even look like
for pregnant women as a whole so we
certainly don't know what long-term
effects look like
for um you know fetuses initially i
would say there was some hesitation
just because i mean at the very
beginning i kind of felt like everyone
else said that
the vaccine may have been a little bit
rushed
but once i had the data in my hands that
hesitation really went away
dr laura riley is an ob gyn at new york
presbyterian now she says
even with the lack of data the benefits
of the vaccine
outrage the worst the risk of covet 19.
these vaccines are what they call
messenger rna vaccine so generally
those are thought to be safe for
pregnant people
another thing to remember here this is
not a live vaccine it doesn't enter or
alter your dna so it's unlikely to also
enter the placenta according to
high-risk pregnancy specialist so
experts at the yale school of medicine
believe
the vaccine does not pose a risk but
just like any vaccine
expectant moms should always check with
their doctor